[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER: OK, everyone.
Let's get started.
Welcome back to Theory of
Computation lecture number six.
So we have been looking at
a number of different models
of computation.
And last lecture actually
was an important one for us,
because we shifted gears
from our restricted models,
finite automata,
pushdown automata,
and their associated generative
models, regular expressions,
and context-free grammars
to Turing machines, which
are going to be the model
that we're going to-- which
is the model that we're
going to be sticking
with for the rest
of the semester,
because that's going to
be our model, as we're
going to argue today, for
a general purpose computer.
So in a sense, everything
we've been doing up till now
or up until that point has
been kind of a warm up.
But it's been nevertheless
has gotten a chance for us
to introduce some
important concepts that
are used in practice and also
will serve as good examples
for us moving forward.
And also just to get kind of
in a sense on the same page.
So what we're going
to be doing today
is looking at the
Turing machine model
in a little bit more depth.
One can define Turing machines
in all sorts of different ways.
But it's going to turn
out not to matter,
because all of
those different ways
are going to be
equivalent to one another.
And so we are going to stick
with the very simplest version,
the one we've already
defined, namely the simple one
tape Turing machine.
But we're going to
basically justify that
by looking at some
of these other models
and proving equivalence.
So we will look at
multi-tape Turing machines,
we'll look at non-deterministic
Turing machines,
and we'll look at another model
which is slightly different
but it's still based on Turing
machines called an enumerator.
And we'll show that
those all in the end
give you the same
class of languages.
And so in that sense, they're
all equivalent to one another.
And that's going to be-- serve
as a kind of a motivator, kind
of in a sense recapitulate some
of the history of the subject,
and going to lead to our
discussion of what's called
the Church Turing thesis.
So we will get to
that in due course.
And we'll also talk about
some notation for notations
for Turing machines and
for encoding objects
to feed into Turing
machines as input,
but we'll get to
that shortly as well.
So let's move on, then.
We will next go into a
little review of what
we did with Turing machines.
And just want to make sure
we're all together on that.
It's a very important
concept for us this term.
So the Turing
machine model looks
like there's going to
be this finite control.
There's a tape with a head that
can read and write on the tape,
can move in both directions.
The tape is infinite
to one side and so on,
as I mentioned last time.
The output of the Turing machine
is either going to be a halt,
accepting or rejecting, or
loop that the machine may
run forever.
With three possible outcomes
for any particular input.
The machine may accept that
input by entering q accept.
May halt and reject
by entering q reject.
And it might reject
by looping, which
means it just never
gets to the accept state
or it never gets
any halting state.
It just goes forever.
But we still consider that
to be rejecting the input,
just it's rejecting by looping.
And as we defined last
time, a language is Turing
recognizable, or as
we typically write,
T recognizable, if it's
the language of some Turing
machine, the collection
of accepted strings
from that Turing machine.
Again, just as
before, the machine
may accept 0 strings,
one string, many strings,
but it always has one
language, the collection of all
accepted strings.
Now, if you have
a decider, which
is a machine that
never loops, which
always halts on
every input, then we
say its language is
a decidable language.
So we'll say a language
is Turing decidable
or simply decidable if it's the
language of some decider, which
is a Turing machine that
always halts on all inputs.
So we have those two
distinct notions,
Turing recognizable
languages and Turning
decidable languages.
Now, as we're going
to argue this lecture,
Turing machines are going to be
our model of a general purpose
computer.
So that's the way we're
going to think of computers
as Turing machines.
And why Turing machines?
Why didn't we pick
something else?
Well, the fact is,
it doesn't matter.
And that's going to be
the point of this lecture.
All reasonable models of
general purpose computation,
unrestricted computation in the
sense of not limited memory,
are all going to be--
all have been shown,
all the models
that we've ever
encountered have all
been shown to be
equivalent to one another.
And so you're free to
pick any one you like.
And so for this
course, we're going
to pick Turing machines
because they're
very simple to argue
about mathematically,
and also they have some
element of familiarity
in that they feel like--
well, they're more familiar than
some of the other models that
have been proposed
that are out there,
such as rewriting systems,
lambda calculus, and so on.
Turing machines feel like a
primitive kind of computer.
And in that sense, they
have a certain familiarity.
OK, so let's start
talking about variations
on the Turing machine model.
And we're going to argue that
it doesn't make any difference.
And then this is
going to be kind
of a precursor to a discussion
of a bit of the history
of the subject that
we're gonna get to
in the second half
of the lecture.
So a multi-tape Turing
machine is a Turing machine,
as you might imagine,
that has more than one--
well, has one or
possibly more tapes.
And so a single
tape Turing machine
would be a special version of
a multi-tape Turing machine.
That's OK.
But you might have
more than one tape,
as I've shown in this diagram.
Now, how do we actually use
a multi-tape Turing machine?
Well, you present the--
and we're going to see these
coming up for convenience.
Sometimes it's nice to be
working with multiple tapes.
So we're going to see these
later on in the semester
a couple of times as well.
But for now, we're
setting the model up
so that the input is going to
be presented on a special input
tape.
So that's where
the input appears,
and it's going to be followed by
blanks, just as we had before.
And now we have these
potentially other tapes,
possibly other tapes, which
we call them work tapes
where the machine can write
other stuff as it wishes.
And those tapes are going
to be initially blank.
So just all blanks on them.
All of the tapes are going
to be read and write.
So you can write
on the input tape.
Obviously you can read
off on the input tape,
and you can read and write
on the other tapes as well.
So what we want to
first establish that
by having these
additional tapes,
you don't get additional power
for the machine in the sense
that you're not going to have--
you won't have
additional languages
that you can recognize
by virtue of having
these additional tapes.
I mean, you can imagine
that having more tapes
will allow you to
do more things.
For example, if you have
a pushdown automaton
with two stacks, you
can do more languages
than you can with one stack.
So it's conceivable that
by having more tapes,
you can do more languages
than you could with one tape.
But in fact, that's
not the case.
One tape is as good
as having many tapes.
And we're going to prove that.
We're going to quickly sketch
through the proof of that fact.
So the theorem is
that a language
is Turing recognizable.
And when we say Turing
recognizable, for now
we mean just with one tape.
So that's the way
we've defined it.
So a language is Turing
recognizable if and only
if some multi-tape
Turing machine recognizes
that language.
So really another
way of saying that is
if you have a language that
you can do with a single tape,
you can do it with a
multi-tape and vice versa.
So one direction of
that is immediate,
because a single tape
Turing machine is already
a multi-tape Turing machine
that just so happens
to have one tape.
So the forward
direction of that is--
there's nothing to say.
That's just immediately true.
But if we want to
prove the reverse,
then we're going to
have to do some work.
And the work is
going to be showing
how do you convert a multi-tape
Turing machine to a single tape
Turing machine.
So if we have something
that's recognized
by a multi-tape Turing machine,
it's still Turing recognizable.
And what that means is that you
can do it with a single tape
Turing machine.
So we have to show how
to do the conversion.
And I'll show you that I
think in a convincing way
but without getting
into too much detail.
So here is an image of a
multi-tape Turing machine
during the course of its input.
So we've already started it off.
Initially it starts off
with the other tapes,
the work tapes being all blank.
But now it's
processed for a while
and the head on
the input tape now
has moved off from its starting
position at the left end.
It's somewhere in the middle.
It's written stuff
on the other tapes.
And what we want
to do is show how
to represent that same
information on a single tape
Turing machine in a way which
allows the single tape Turing
machine to carry out the
steps of the multi-tape Turing
machine but using only
a single tape by virtue
of some kind of a data structure
which allows for the simulation
to go forward.
So how is the single tape Turing
machine going to be simulating,
going to be carrying out
the same effect of having
these multiple tapes on the
multi-tape Turing machine?
So here's a picture of the
single tape Turing machine.
It just has one tape.
By the way, I should mention
that all of the tapes
are infinite to the right in
the multi-tape Turing machine,
just as we had for the
single tape Turing machine.
And now with this single
tape Turing machine,
it's going to represent
the information that's
present on these multiple tapes
but using only the single tape.
And the way I'm
choosing to do that
is going to be
particularly simple.
I'm going to just divide up,
so here I'm saying it in words.
It's going to
simulate m by storing
the contents of the
multi-tape on the single tape
in separate blocks.
So I'm basically going to
divide up the single tape Turing
machines tape into
separate regions where
each one of those
regions is going
to have the information
that was on one
of the tapes in the
multi-tape machine.
So for example, on the first
tape it's got a, a, b, a.
Well, that's going
to appear here
in that first block on the
single tape Turing machine.
Sort of seeing it
float down to suggest
that it's coming from this
multi-tape Turing machine.
But that's really been
developed by the simulation
that the single tape
Turing machine has.
Obviously the single
tape Turing machine
doesn't have any direct access
to the multi-tape machine.
But it's going to be simulating.
So this is how we're
showing the data is
being stored on the
single tape machines tape.
So in the second
block, it's going
to have the contents of the
second tape of the Turing
multi-tape machine.
And the final region
of the single tapes,
the final block so-called of
the single tape's tape is going
to have-- the single
tape machine's tape--
it's going to have the
rest of the contents
of the last tape of m.
And then it's going
to be followed
by the same infinitely many
blanks that each of these tapes
are going to have
following the portion
that they may have
written during the course
of their computation.
So that's what the single
tape Turing machine's tape
is going to look like during
the course of its computation.
It's going to have the
information represented
in these blocks.
Capturing all of the information
that the multi-tape Turing
machine has in a perhaps
somewhat less convenient way,
because the multi-tape
Turing machine,
we didn't really
make this explicit.
And in part because it
doesn't really matter,
we didn't say exactly how the
multi tape machine operates.
What I have in mind is that
the multi-tape Turing machine
can read and move
all of its heads
from all of its
heads in one step.
So in a single step of
the multi-tape machine,
it can obtain the
information that's
underneath each of
its heads, feed that
in through its
transition function,
and then together with the
state of the multi-tape machine
decide how to change
each of those locations
and then how to move
each one of those heads.
So it's kind of operating on
all of the tapes in parallel.
So now how does the actual
steps of the simulation
of the single tape--
by the single tape
machine, how does it go?
So first of all, besides
storing the contents
of each of the tapes
in S's single tape,
there's some
additional information
that it needs to record.
Namely, M has a head for
each one of its tapes.
But S has just a single head.
And each of M's heads could
be in some different location.
In this case, as I've shown
it, on the first tape,
its head is in location three.
On the second tape,
it's in location two.
On the third tape, it's on
location-- on the last tape,
it's in location one.
So where were we?
We were simulating the
multi-tape Turing machine
with the single
tape Turing machine.
And we had to keep track
of where the heads are.
And so we're going
to do that by writing
the locations on those blocks.
So we're going to have a
special dot, as I've shown here,
to represent the location of the
head in that very first block.
So the head's on the b.
I'm going to dot the b.
And I'm going to do the
same thing for the locations
of the other heads.
And how am I
getting that effect?
Well, we've seen
something like that
before, where we just expand
the tape alphabet of S
to allow for these
dotted symbols as well
as the irregular symbols.
We also have expanded it to
include the delimiter markers
that separate the
blocks from one
another, which I'm
writing as a pound sign.
So we can just get
that effect simply
by expanding the
tape alphabet of S.
A few more details of S that
are just worth looking at,
just to make sure we're
kind of all understanding
what's happening.
So for every time
M takes one step,
S has actually a
lot of work to do.
Because one step of M can
read and move all of those
heads all at one shot.
S has to scan the
entire tape to see
what's underneath those in
effect virtual heads, which
are the locations of
the dotted symbols.
It has to see what's underneath
each one of those heads
to see how to update its
state to the next state.
And then it has to scan
again to change the location,
change the contents of
those tape locations,
and also to move the head left
or right by effectively now
moving the dot left or right.
So that's pretty
straightforward.
There's one complication
that can occur, however,
which is that what happens if
on one of the tapes, let's say,
M starts writing
more content than you
have room in that block
to store that information?
So if M, it has
1, 0, 1, suppose M
after a few steps moves its
head into the originally
blank portion of the tape and
writes another symbol there.
We have to put that
symbol somewhere,
because we have to record
all that information.
And the block is full.
So what do we do?
Well, in that case, S goes
to a little interrupt routine
and moves, shifts all of the
symbols to the right one place
to open up a location here
where it can write a new symbol
for continuing the simulation.
So with that in mind, S can
maintain the current contents
of each of of M's tapes.
And let me just note that here.
Shift to add room is needed.
And that's all that
happens during the course
of the simulation.
And of course, if S
as it's simulating M
observes that M comes to
an accept or reject state,
S should do the same.
So that's our description
of how the single tape
simulation of the
multi-tape machine works.
Let's turn to
non-deterministic machines.
Now, if you remember
for finite, and I
hope you do, for
finite automata,
we had equivalence between
non-deterministic and
deterministic.
Finite automata.
For pushdown automata, we
did not have the equivalence.
We didn't prove that, but
we just stated it as a fact.
There are certain
languages that you
can do with non-deterministic
pushdown automata, which
is the model we typically
hold as our standard.
So that some things you can do
with non-deterministic automata
that you cannot do with
deterministic pushdown
automata.
You really need the
non-determinism.
They're not equivalent.
For Turing machines, we're going
to get the equivalence back.
So we'll show that
anything you can
do with a non-deterministic
Turing machine in terms
of language recognition,
you can also
do with a deterministic
Turing machine.
So remember, we kind of
mentioned this briefly
last time, the
non-deterministic Turing machine
looks exactly like a
deterministic Turing machine
except for the
transition function
where we have this
power set, which
allows for multiple
different outcomes at a given
step instead of just
a single outcome
that you would have in
a deterministic machine.
So we represent that
with this power set here
applied to the possibilities
that the machine would
have as the next step.
So now we're going to prove
a very similar theorem,
that A is Turing recognizable
by an ordinary one tape Turing
machine.
That kind of goes
without saying,
since that's how we defined it.
It's Turing
recognizable if and only
of some non-deterministic
Turing machine
recognizes the language.
Again, remember we're
using non-determinism
in the way we always do.
Namely that a
non-deterministic machine
accepts if there is some
branch or some thread
of its computation
ends up at an accept.
Other branches might go forever
or might reject part of the way
through.
But acceptance always overrules
then if any branch accepts.
That's how non-determinism
works for us.
So now the forward
direction of this
is, again, just like
before, immediate
because a deterministic
Turing machine
is a special kind of
non-deterministic Turing
machine which never branches
non-deterministically
on any of its steps.
So that forward
direction is immediate.
The backwards
definition is where
we're going to have to
do some work converting
our non-deterministic
Turing machine
to a deterministic
Turing machine.
And we'll do so as follows.
We'll take a non-deterministic
Turing machine.
Here is our picture.
And we're going to now
imagine its computation
in terms of a tree.
And so here is the
non-deterministic computation
tree for n on some input w.
So n for non-deterministic.
Here is the tree.
Somewhere down here it
might end up accepting.
And as I mentioned,
that is going
to be defining the
overall computation
to be accepting if there is some
place here that's accepting.
And the only way it can be
non-accepting computation
if there is no accept
that occurs anywhere.
And somehow if you're
going to convert
this non-deterministic machine
to a deterministic machine,
the deterministic
machine is going
to have to get that same effect.
It doesn't have the
non-determinism.
So how does it manage that?
Well, it's really going to be
carrying out the simulation
kind of as you would imagine
doing it yourself if you were
told you had to simulate
a non-deterministic Turing
machine, which is
you're going to search
that tree of
possibilities looking
to see if you find and accept.
If you do, then you accept.
If you don't, well,
maybe you'll go forever
or maybe you'll manage to
search the entire tree,
and then you will say, no,
I accept, no, I reject.
So let's just see,
again, what the data
structure of that
deterministic machine's tape
is going to look like.
So the way this simulation
is going to carry out,
and you could program this
in a host of different ways.
And in fact, the textbook has a
somewhat different simulation.
But I think this one here lends
itself a little bit better
and maybe it's a little
simpler for description
in this setting.
But there's lots of different
ways of improving these things.
So m is going to simulate
n kind of a little bit
similar to the
previous simulation.
It's going to break the
tape up into blocks,
and it's going to now
store in each block
a different thread at a
particular point in time
of n's computation.
So you imagine where m
is going to be simulating
n sort of doing the
same parallelism
but getting the effect
of the parallelism
not through the non-determinism
but by maintaining copies
of each of the
threads on its tape
and then updating
them accordingly.
So the idea is, I think,
not too complicated.
So let's just see some
of the details here.
So here populating those
blocks with the contents of n's
tape on different threads.
Maybe that corresponds
to n's tape
after the fifth step of n
on each of those threads.
You have these three
possibilities, let's say,
written down as three
different blocks.
Now, remember in the case of
the multi-tape simulation,
we needed to record
some extra information.
In particular, we had to record
the location of the heads
by using those dotted symbols.
We're going to do that
again because each one
of these threads
might have their head
in some different location.
But we're going to
have to do more.
So let's do one thing at a time.
We're going to store
the head location.
Here they are all written
down as dotted symbols.
But now there's something
that goes further.
Because in a multi-tape case,
there was one global state
that the multi-tape
machine was in,
of course, at any given time.
It's just that one has
one finite control.
It's in one state.
But in the case of the
non-deterministic machine
that we're simulating
now, each thread
can be in a different state.
So whereas before,
we could keep track
of the multi-tape machine's
state inside the single tape
machine's finite control.
Now there could be many,
many different states
to keep track of.
So you won't be able to store
that in a finite control
anymore, because there could
be some huge number of threads
active at any given stage.
And some of them
can be one state.
Others can be in
different state.
And how do you keep
track of all that?
So we're going to
have to use the tape.
We're going to actually write
down which state a given
thread is in on that block.
And we'll do that.
I'll show it like this.
So writing down the state
of each thread in the block
by writing down symbols which
correspond to those states.
So we're actually in a sense
writing the states down right
on top of the block
using symbols that
correspond to those states.
So again, we're
getting that effect
by increasing the
tape alphabet of M
to include symbols
that correspond
to each of its states.
And we're going to write
those symbols down.
So here's the
symbol for state q8
that says, well, that very
first thread of n's computation
is in state q8.
It's in this third
position on its tape.
The head is on the
third position there.
And the tape contents
is a, a, b, a.
That's how we represent that
thread of the computation
including the state.
So M is going to carry out
that step by step maintaining
that information on its tape.
Again, similar to
before, there might
be some special
situations arising.
So for example, n is
non-deterministic.
So a thread might
fork into two threads.
What do we do then?
Well, sort of the
reasonable thing.
If there's a forking
thread, M then
copies that block, makes
two copies of the block
to correspond, or however
many copies you need,
to correspond to
the possibilities
that that thread
is branching into.
So you want to represent
them all on different blocks
of M's tape.
All right?
And then if M ever finds out
that on one of the threads
it's entering the
accept state, it
can just shut down the whole
computation at that point
and say accept.
So perhaps a little elaborate,
but I think conceptually,
hopefully, not too bad.
Now, let's move on then
to talk about somewhat
of a different looking--
well, sort of a different
model, in a way, which
has some historical significance
and sometimes is a helpful way
to look at Turing
recognizability.
And incidentally, you
have a homework problem
on this model called
an enumerator or Turing
enumerator.
So here it's going to
operate somewhat differently.
First of all, we're going to
enhance the Turing machine
model.
It's going to now have
just a single tape.
But it's going to
also have a printer.
So we're now adding
in this new device
into the Turing machine
called a printer.
And the Turing machine
has tape as before,
except we never provide
any input to the machine.
The tape always starts
out fully blank.
It's only used for
reading and writing.
Only used for work.
It's not where you
present the input.
So how do you talk about
the language of the machine?
Well, the way you work
this machine is you
take this enumerator.
It's a deterministic Turing
machine with a printer,
as I mentioned.
You started off in blank tape.
And it runs and runs and
runs and periodically it
can print a string under some
sort of program control, which
I'm not going to
spell out for you.
But you can imagine
you might have
to define the
machine in such a way
that when it goes into
a certain print state,
we're not going to set
that all up, then whatever
string is in a certain
region of the tape
maybe from the start point up
into the head location, that
gets printed out on the printer.
And then it can print out
other strings in due course.
And so periodically, you
think of this printer
as printing out a string under
the control of the Turing
machine enumerator.
And so these print strings,
these strings that could
print out w1, w2, they appear.
And the machine might
possibly go forever and print
infinitely many strings.
Or it might go forever and only
print finitely many strings.
Or it might stop after a while
by entering a halting state.
Accepting or rejecting
is irrelevant,
but it enters a halting state.
And then the strings
that it's print out,
the finitely many
strings it printed out,
that's the output
of the machine.
Now, the language of the
machine is the collection
of all strings that
it ever prints out.
So we're defining language in
a somewhat different way here.
It's not the strings
that it accepts.
It's the strings that it prints.
So we think of this
machine almost a little bit
analogous to the
regular expression
or the grammar in the sense
that it's a generative model.
It produces the language
rather than accepts the strings
in the language.
It's not really a recognizer.
It's a generator.
And the language of the
machine, as writing over here,
for an enumerator here, we say
its language is a collection
of strings that it prints.
Now we will show that a
language is Turing recognizable
in the previous sense recognized
by some ordinary Turing
machine if and only if it's the
language of some enumerator.
And actually this is
kind of a little bit
of an interesting proof.
You have to do some work.
It's an if only if.
Now neither direction
is immediate.
You're going to have to do
some work in both directions.
One direction is a little
harder than the other.
We'll start off with
the easier direction.
Let's say we have an enumerator.
Hopefully you got this
concept of this Turing machine
which periodically prints
strings when you started it off
on the empty tape.
So now what I'm going
to construct for you
is that Turing
machine recognizer
defined from the enumerator.
So this recognizer is going to
be simulating the enumerator.
So basically that recognizer is
going to launch the enumerator.
It's going to start
off simulating it.
Now, if you want,
if it's convenient,
we could use several tapes.
We can use one tape to
simulate the recognizer
and you have other tapes
available for convenience
if you want, because
we already showed
multi-tape and single
tape are equivalent.
So if you want, you can think
of M as having multiple tapes.
It's not going to really be that
relevant to my conversation.
But you're going to simulate
E starting on the blank input,
as you're supposed to.
And then you're going to
see whenever E prints in x,
you're going to see
if x is the same
as the input to the recognizer.
You get the idea?
So we have a recognizer.
It has an input string,
maybe like 1, 1, 0, 1.
And I want to know.
I want to accept that string
if it's one of the strings
that the enumerator E
prints out, because that's
what the recognizer do.
It's supposed to
accept all the strings
that the enumerator prints out.
So I got this 1, 1, 0, 1.
What do I do?
I fire up that numerator,
I get it going,
and I start watching the
strings it prints out,
comparing them with my
input string, 1, 1, 0, 1.
If I ever see it print
out a 1, 1, 0, 1, great.
I know I can accept,
because I know it's
in the enumerator's language.
But if I compare and
compare and compare,
I never see the enumerator
ever printing out
my input string 1, 1, 0, 1.
Well, I just keep simulating.
If E halts, well then
I can halt and reject
if I've never seen that string
coming out as an output.
If E doesn't halt, well, I'm
just not going to halt either.
I'm going to go forever.
But then I'm going to be
rejecting my input by looping.
So that's the
proof of converting
in this backward direction,
which is the easier direction.
Now let's look at the
forward direction,
which has a certain
wrinkle in it that we're
going to have to get to.
So now we're going to be
building our enumerator
to simulate our recognizer.
And the way we'll do
that is the enumerator
has to print out
all of the strings
that the recognizer
would ever accept.
So you kind of do
the obvious thing.
You're going to take--
the enumerator is going to
start simulating the recognizer
M on all possible strings.
Sort of one by one, doing them
in parallel, taking turns.
Maybe we didn't make
this so explicit.
But you can sort of timeshare
among several different
possibilities.
Sort of like having different
blocks for the machine.
The enumerator is going
to run the recognizer on--
well, let's just say it
does it sequentially.
It runs it on the empty string.
It runs it on the string 0.
It runs it on the string one.
Runs it on the string 0, 0.
These are all the possible
strings of sigma star.
You run on all of them.
And whenever the enumerator--
uh oh.
This is wrong.
So whenever M
accepts, then print--
I can't write very well.
Print w, wi.
Oops.
OK.
So I'm going to just
say it in words.
I'm want to simulate
M on each wi.
Whenever you notice M accepting
wi, you just print out wi.
Because you want to print
out all of the strings
that M accepts.
Now, there is a problem here.
So hopefully you're not
confused by this typo.
Doing it sequentially
like I just described
doesn't quite work.
So let me just
back that up here.
Doing it sequentially
doesn't quite work,
because M might get stuck
looping on one of the wi's.
Like maybe when I feed 0
into M, M goes forever.
Because M is rejecting
0 by looping.
But maybe it also
accepts this next string
in the list, the string one.
I'll never get to one by just
feeding the strings into M one
by one like this.
What I really have to do
is run all of the strings
in M in parallel.
And the way I'm
going to indicate
that is I want to simulate
M on w1 to wi for i steps
for each possible i.
So I'm going to run M on more
and more strings for more
and more steps.
And every time I notice
that M accepts something,
I print it out.
So I will fix this in
the version of the file
that I publish on the website.
So if you're still not getting
it, you can look there.
But just to make
things even worse,
I have a check in, which is
going to be about this one
little point here.
So I got a question.
Where do we get the wi strings?
The wi strings are
simply the list
of all strings in sigma star.
So under program
control, we can make M go
through every possible string.
Like if you had an
odometer, you're
going to first get
to the empty string.
Then you go to the string
0, then the string one.
You can write a program
which is going to do that.
And the Turing
machine can similarly
write code to do that, to get
to each possible string one
by one.
And then that's what
the enumerator is doing.
It's obtaining each
of those strings
and then feeding them into
M, seeing what M does.
What I'm trying
to get at here is
that it's not good to
feed them in, run M
to completion on each one
before going to the next one.
You really kind of have
to do them all in parallel
to avoid the problem of
getting stuck on one string
that M is looping on.
All right.
So this is relevant to
your homework, in fact.
If I convert em to an
enumerator in this way,
does that enumerator always
print the strings out
in string order.
String order is this order here.
Having the shorter
strings coming up
before the longer strings
and within strings
of a certain length, just doing
them in lexicographical order.
So hopefully you follow that.
But since these are not correct,
this doesn't matter for us.
Let me launch that poll.
I'll see how random
the answer is here.
So a fair amount of confusion.
If you're confused, obviously
you're in good company there.
About to shut this down.
Five seconds to go.
OK, ending it now.
All right.
So the correct answer, as
the majority of you did get,
is in fact that the order is
not going to be respected here
when E prints things out.
It might print out some
things later in the order
before earlier
things in the order.
What's going to control when
E is going to print it out?
If M accepts some strings
more quickly in fewer steps,
then E might end up printing
out that string earlier
in the list than some
other string that
might be a shorter string.
Because the order in which
E is going to now identify
that M is accepting
those strings
depends upon the speed
with which M is actually
doing the accepting.
So this is relevant to
one of your homeworks,
because what you're
going to have to show
is that if you start with a
decidable language instead
of a recognizable
language, then you
can make an enumerator, which
always prints out things
in order, in the string order.
And vice versa.
And if you have an enumerator
which prints that things out
in string order, then the
language is decidable.
So need to think about that.
One direction is a fairly
simple modification
of what I just showed.
The other direction is a
little bit of more work.
So anyway, why don't we take
our little coffee break here?
So that's an
interesting question.
So one question is because
sigma has an infinite-- sigma
star is infinite,
if I understand
this question
correctly, which says
it's an infinite
number of strings here.
How does the machine
even get started
because it has to go through
and enumerate all of it?
No, it's not first writing
down all of those strings.
Because yeah, you
can't write down--
you can't do this infinite
step of writing down
all the strings.
What I had in mind
is you're going
to take each string in turn.
First you're going to
take the first string
on the list of sigma star,
run M on that string,
and then the next
string in sigma star,
run it on that string, and
so on, string after string.
And so you're never going to
have infinitely many strings
to deal with.
It's just going to be
more and more strings
as you're going along.
And the question I
was trying to get at
is whether you're going to
run each one to completion
before you get to the next one
or you're going to kind of try
to do them all in
parallel, which is what you
need to do to prove this there.
Won't there be
infinitely many wi?
Yes, so there are
a-- similar question.
Infinitely many wi.
There are infinitely many wi.
But it's just an infinite
loop that we're in.
One by one, you're taking
care of more and more wi
as you're going.
Let's see here.
Yes.
So another question
is are we running
all the strings in parallel?
Yes, we are running all of
the strings in parallel.
But it's running them in
parallel, but these are--
we're not defining a
parallel Turing machine.
It's running them in
parallel using time sharing.
It runs a little
bit in this block,
runs a little bit in that
block and another block,
and sort of shifts
around and sort of does
a few steps of each.
And that's how it's getting
the effect of the parallelism.
Question is would the
enumerator essentially
have a print tape
and a work tape?
Yeah, you can think of it
as having a print tape.
However you want
to formalize it.
It doesn't matter.
I mean, I'm being a little
whimsical with attaching it
to a picture of a real printer.
But yeah, you think conceptually
you can have a print tape.
However you like to
think about it is fine.
How can we directly say
that without knowing
the program of the printer?
We don't have to get into
the structure of the printer.
The printer is just something
where you say print a string
and a string comes out.
That's all we know
about the printer,
and that's all we need to know.
So there's no program
for the printer.
Sorry if I'm not
understanding your question.
But the question
literally says, how can we
say that without knowing
the name of the printer?
So if the machine
is decidable, why
does it have to print
all strings in order?
For example, if one
string is shorter,
can it be decided later?
Well, yeah.
The reason why we want--
so the question is, if
the machine is decidable,
why does it have to print
all strings in order?
Because that's what I'm asking
you to do in the problem.
If you read the problem, I think
it's number five on the P set.
That's what I'm
asking you to do.
That's why you have
to print it in order.
Otherwise you wouldn't have to
worry about printing in order.
It's just because
I'm asking you to.
OK, so I think
we're out of time.
Let us move back
into our material.
Second half,
Church-Turing thesis.
So Church, this is
going back into the bit
of the history of the
subject back to the 1930s.
Back then people were
interested in formulating
the notion of what do
we mean by algorithm.
They didn't even
call it algorithm.
Some people call it procedure.
Some people called it
effective procedure.
effective calculation.
But people had in their
minds-- mathematicians
have been dealing for
centuries, thousands of years,
with procedures
for doing things.
That's a very natural thing.
And mathematical logicians, in
particular Church and Turing,
Turing somebody surely
obviously you've
heard of, Church maybe not.
Church was Turing's
thesis advisor, in fact.
And they both were coming
out of the mathematical logic
field of mathematics and trying
to use mathematical logic
to formalize this
intuitive notion of what
we have had for centuries
about what a procedure is,
what is an algorithm.
And back in those
days, they came up
with different ways
of formalizing it.
So here we had this
notion of algorithm, which
is kind of intuitive concept.
Turing proposed Turing
machine as a way
of capturing that
in a formal way,
a mathematically precise way.
Other people came up with
other ways of doing it.
And back then, it
wasn't obvious that all
of those different
formulations would end up
giving you equivalent
concepts, equivalent notions.
And in fact, they proved
in fairly elaborate detail
that the different methods
that people came up
with, there was the
lambda calculus,
there was rewriting systems,
there were several methods
that were proposed for
formalizing this notion,
and they all turned out to
be equivalent to one another.
Today that seems
kind of obvious,
even though I went
to some effort
to prove that just to
give you a feeling for how
those things go.
If you have programs, if
you have Pascal and Java,
say, and thinking about what
you can do mathematically
in those--
I'm not talking
about their ability
to interface with Windows
and so on, but just
the mathematical capabilities.
The capability of doing
mathematical calculations
or functions with a Pascal
program or a Java program.
It would be absurd to think
there's some program that you
can write in Java that you
can't write in Pascal or Python.
And the reason is we know you
can compile Python into Java
and you can compile
Java back into Python.
That tells you that the two
systems, two programming
languages are
equivalent in power.
That wasn't obvious from
the get go to these folks.
So they observed that all of
the different efforts that
came at formalizing
algorithm, all
were equivalent to one another.
That was kind of a
breakthrough moment
when they realized that all of
the ways that they've come up
with, and once
they got the idea,
they realized all
reasonable ways of doing it
are always going
to be equivalent.
And so that suggested
that they've really
captured this
notion of algorithm
by any one of those methods,
say a Turing machine.
And that's what they took.
You can't prove that, because
algorithms are an intuitive
notion.
But the fact that we're able to
capture that in a formal way,
that's what we call today
the Church-Turing thesis.
So any of these methods
captured the notion of algorithm
as we described.
And that has had a big
impact on mathematics.
Just give me one second here.
All right.
Here's a check in on this one.
So you know Alan Turing.
So here are some facts
which may or may not
be true about Alan Turing.
So now you get to pick
all of the ones that
apply based on your knowledge.
Obviously this is more for
fun or historical interest.
But let's launch that poll.
See how much you know
about Mr. Turing.
Check all that apply.
OK, almost done?
Please let's wrap it up.
I think that's everybody.
OK, two seconds.
Please get credit
for doing this.
End polling.
In fact, it's kind
of interesting here.
You all do know that
he was a code breaker.
He worked, in fact,
was part of a team,
I think led the team,
which broke the German code
during World War II.
The Turing test
is a famous thing
for how do you
characterize when you
have an intelligent machine.
So he definitely worked in AI.
He worked in biology as well.
He has a paper less well
known to computer scientists.
But if you look him
up on Wikipedia,
where I get all my
information, he actually,
and I knew this anyway, he
has a very famous paper,
an influential paper, on
how, for example, spots
arise on leopards and
stripes on tigers and so on.
Gave a kind of
mathematical model for that
which actually proves--
actually is quite--
does capture things
in an accurate way, as was
shown subsequent to that.
Was imprisoned for being gay.
In fact, as far as I
know from his history,
he was not in prison
for being gay.
He was convicted of being
gay and was given a choice
to go to prison or
to take chemicals
to cure him from being gay.
And he opted not to go to
prison and take the chemicals.
And sadly, he committed
suicide two years after that.
So he was treated very
badly by British society
and British government despite
having the great work that he
had done.
And you might think that he
has been honored by appearing
on a British banknote.
That's also not true.
But the good news is
he's not currently
on a British banknote,
but he's going
to be on a British banknote
starting next year.
So that's along with Winston
Churchill and a number
of other notable Brits.
He's going to be on
the 50 pound banknote.
OK, so let us continue.
So as I mentioned,
the Church-Turing
was important for mathematics.
And it has to do with
these Hilbert problems.
I don't know how many of
you have encountered that.
David Hilbert was
widely considered
to be the perhaps the greatest
mathematician of his day.
And every four
years, mathematicians
get together for an
international congress,
well, the International
Congress of Mathematicians.
That's been going on
for over 100 years.
And he was invited
to the 1900 meeting
to give a talk about
anything he wanted.
And what he decided to do
during that presentation
is present 23
problems that would
be a challenge for
mathematicians for the coming
century.
And we're running a
little short on time,
so I'm not going
to go into them.
Some of these we'll
talk about later.
But the 10th problem
here is about algorithms.
The 10th problem
on Hilbert's list
called Hilbert's 10th problem
is a problem about algorithms.
And it says give an algorithm
for solving what are
called Diophantine equations.
He didn't call it an algorithm.
He called it some finite
procedure or something
like that.
But what are
Diophantine equations?
I'm glad you asked.
Diophantine equations.
What are they?
Well, they're very simple.
They're just
polynomial equations,
like does this polynomial equal
some constant, for example.
But where you're looking
for the solutions,
the polynomials are variables.
You're looking
for the solutions,
but you're only allowing the
solutions to be integers.
So here's an example.
So I give you this polynomial.
Here I'm setting it equal to 7.
And I want to solve
that equation.
So it has these three
variables, x, y, and z.
So you have to find
a solution there.
But I'm only going to allow
you to have plug in integers.
And in fact, there is
a solution in integers.
1, 2, and minus 2.
If you plug it in,
you'll see it works.
All right.
Now, the general problem
that Hilbert was addressing
is suppose I give
you a polynomial.
Let's say it's set to 0.
So we're looking for
roots of the polynomial.
But just some
polynomial equation.
You can always put
it in this form.
And I want to know does it
have a solution in integers?
And what I'm looking
for is a procedure
which will tell me yes or no.
I want to know.
Give an algorithm to answer
that question for a given
polynomial.
Or using the language
of this course,
defining this in terms of a
language, decide this language.
Give a Turing machine which will
decide yes or no for any given
polynomial.
Yes there is a
solution in integers.
No, there is no
That was what Hilbert
asked in his 10th problem.
Give an algorithm.
Now, as we know now,
it took seven years
to get the answer that
there is no such algorithm.
It's an undecidable problem.
And we'll talk about that a
little bit later in the term.
But D is not a
decidable language.
Now, there was no hope of coming
up with that answer in 1900
or even in 1910,
because we didn't
have a formal idea of
what an algorithm is.
That had to wait until the
Church-Turing thesis told us
that algorithms really
are Turing machines,
that there is a formal way of
saying what an algorithm is.
And once you had
that notion, then you
could prove that there
is no Turing machine.
But before that, you had only
this vague notion, intuitive
notion of what an algorithm is.
And so there was no
hope of ever answering
that, because in
fact, the answer is
there is no such algorithm.
Now, I'll give this as a
little exercise to you.
We're a little bit
running short on time.
But this language D is in
fact a recognizable language.
So I would suggest you
think about that offline.
But basically, you can try
plugging in different values
for these variables.
And if you ever find
that it evaluates to 0,
then you can accept.
But otherwise, you just have
to keep going and looking.
So showing recognizability
is very simple,
but decidability is false.
Now let's talk a little
bit about encodings
for Turing machines.
So we're going to be working--
encodings and Turing machines.
So we're now going to be working
with Turing machines going
forward.
The input to those Turing
machines might be polynomials,
might be strings.
They might be other things too.
We might want to feed automata
into the Turing machines.
So the Turing machine can answer
questions about the automata.
Well, don't forget, Turing
machines take as their input
just strings.
So we have to think
about how we're
going to represent
something more complicated
like an automaton as a string.
And I'm not going to get
into the details of that.
You could spell
it out in detail.
But I think that's not too
interesting to get into that.
We're just going to
develop a notation that
says if you have some object,
it could be a polynomial.
There could be an automaton.
It could be a graph.
It could be whatever
you're working with.
A table.
I'm going to write that
O in these brackets
to mean an encoding of
that object into a string.
And then you can feed the
string into the Turing machine.
So that's how we're going to be
thinking of presenting Turing
machines with more complicated
objects and strings as input,
because we're just
going to represent them
as strings using ways in which
I'm sure you're all familiar.
I mean, that's how you deal
with representing stuff when
you write your programs anyway.
But just to make it
formal and that's the way
we're going to write it
down in these brackets.
And if you have a list
of several objects
that you want to present
together to a Turing machine,
we'll just write them together
within brackets like this.
Now, for writing Turing
machines down, going forward,
we're going to be using high
level English descriptions.
We're not going to be
worrying about managing--
like the stuff we've been
doing up till now, I'm
not going to ask you to do it.
We're not going to
do that anymore,
and I'm not going
to ask you to do it.
Managing where stuff goes on
the tapes and all that stuff,
that's too low level.
Because really now that we
have the Church-Turing thesis,
we're really interested in
talking about algorithms.
We're not that interested in
talking about Turing machines,
per se.
We're interested in
algorithms and what
the power of computation is.
So we're going to only be
talking about Turing machines
now in a higher level way.
And only when we need to prove
something about capabilities,
we're going to come
back to Turing machines
and we're going to be proving
things about their limitations
and so on.
So our notation for
running Turing machines
is going to be--
we're basically going to
put the Turing machine
inside these quotation marks.
And we're going to know that
we could in principle write out
the Turing machine in a
precise way in terms of states
and transition
function and so on,
but we'll never
actually go ahead
and do that lengthy exercise.
So quick check in here.
So one of the features-- well,
OK, let me not give this away.
So if x and y are
strings, I want
to now have a way of presenting
two strings as a single string
as input to my machine, because
I always think of my machine
as getting a single input.
So would you suggest one way of
combining two strings into one
which would be a good encoding
is just to concatenate
those two strings together.
Would that be the
way you would do it?
Is that a good way to do it or
not such a good way to do it?
So let's see here.
I can get to that next.
And think of what you
would want to have
happen in a good encoding.
Ready, set, sold.
Share results.
Yeah.
I think most of you get
the idea that this is not
a good way of combining
two strings into one,
because the problem is it's
kind of ambiguous in a sense.
If you combine two
strings this way,
what's important in an
encoding is that the machine
when it gets the encoding,
it can decode them back
into the original objects.
And if you're just going
to be sticking the two
strings together, you don't
know where one string ends
and the next string begins.
And so it's not going to be a
good way of combining things.
You should find a little
bit more clever way
of either introducing
another symbol
or doing something a little
bit more sophisticated,
which would allow you to
be able to do the decoding
as well as the encoding
in a unique way.
So getting back to that
notation for a Turing machine.
So here is the
machine we've already
seen once before for a to the
k, b to the k, c to the k.
I would write it now more simply
than managing all of the tapes
that we had the first
time around, which
we did last lecture.
I would just say we
give it an input w,
check if w's of the right
form with the things
in the right order.
Reject if it's not.
Count the number of
a's b's and c's in w.
Accept if all the counts
are equal and reject if not.
That's going to be good
enough to be writing things
at that higher level when
you're going to be writing
your algorithm descriptions.
You just have to make sure
that whatever you're doing
you can implement.
You don't want to be doing
tests which are impossible
or doing infinitely
much work in one stage.
That's not good.
But as long as it's clear
that what you're doing
is doing only a finite
amount of work in every stage
and it's something that
you could really implement,
you can write it
in a high level.
I wanted to spend a few minutes
talking about problem set two,
but we're a little bit
running out of time here.
Particularly there was
this problem number five
where you show that a language
is Turing recognizable if
and only if there's
a decidable D. Where
C is Turing recognizable where
D is now a collection of pairs.
We've got some questions
about the notation, which
I've hopefully answered now.
So C is a set of x's
such that there exists
a string you can pair it with.
So that the string xy is in D.
Let me try to give
you a picture of that.
So I want to think of D as a
collection of pairs of strings.
And it might be helpful to think
of D kind of on the axes here.
So if we have a pair of strings
xy, which I have not yet
packaged into a
single string, I'm
thinking of them as a pair of
two objects at this moment,
think of D as--
so just the x part is just
below here on the x-axis.
D you might just
conceptually want
to think of it as a
collection of pairs.
So it's like a subset
of all of these pairs.
And C is all of the x's that
correspond to any pair in here.
Sometimes we call
that the projection,
because it's all the things
that are below or the shadow.
If you had a light
sitting up here,
it's all the things that
are kind of underneath a D.
So I've written C here
kind of a little thicker,
if you can see that.
So that's the C language.
And there's two directions here.
One is a lot easier
than the other.
If I give you a
decidable D and I
want to test whether something's
in C, so I'll give you an x,
I want to know is x in C?
Well, you now have to test is
there some y that I can pair
with x where the pair is in D?
So you can start
looking for that y.
If you ever find
one, you know that x
is in C. There are infinitely
many y's to look for.
But don't forget, you're only
looking for a recognizer for C.
So on the rejecting side,
you're allowed to go forever.
So I'm kind of giving
you a way to think
about the easy direction.
The hard direction, you need
to think about how are you
going to come up with that
decidable D. If I give you C,
you have to find a
decidable D. And now
you're bringing
something down lower.
You're starting with a
recognizable language
and a decidable
language, which is
going to sort of be counterpart
to that and in a sense
is a simpler language.
And the way it
becomes simpler is
that y is going to help you
determine whether x is in C.
And I guess the thing that
I'll leave you with is,
and maybe we can talk about this
a little bit more on Tuesday,
I'll try to leave a
little more time if you
want to test if something
is in C, x is in C,
but I don't want to let you go
forever anymore, because I want
to be a decidable language.
And I'm going to
use y to help you.
What information would
help you guarantee
you get the right
answer for x being in C?
But that you would
have to be sure
you're getting the right answer.
So y could just be the answer.
But then you don't know
that that's-- you have to be
convinced that you
have the right answer.
y just saying what
it is, I mean,
y could say that x is in
D even when it's not true.
x is in C even when
that's not true.
So what information would allow
you to check that x is in C?
What would be
helpful information
to check that x is in C
where you would avoid ever
having to go forever?
A little bit too rushed
here for that to be helpful.
Anyway, let's just
conclude what we've done.
Just brief summary here.
And I don't want to
keep you over time.
So I'll just leave
this up on the board.
I will see if there's any--
so the lecture is over
and you can take
off as you wish.
I will stick around for
a couple of minutes.
I have another meeting soon, but
I'll try to answer some chats.
All right.
People are commenting about
this movie about Turing,
The Imitation Game.
If you haven't seen
that, I recommend it.
And is it a good idea to make
y to be equal to the repeated
looped string?
Hm.
I'm not sure about that.
Thank you, everybody, for
sending your kind notes.
Church-Turing thesis.
The question is
is it in the book?
Yes.
It's in the book.
Kind of similar to what
I've already said, but yes.
OK, this is a good
question here.
The Church-Turing thesis.
Somebody asked me, is
it proved in the book?
There's nothing to prove.
The Church-Turing
thesis is an equivalence
between the intuitive
and the formal.
You can't prove
something like that.
You can just make--
it's really in a
sense a hypothesis
that the only thing you'll
ever be able to compute
is something that you can
do with a Turing machine.
I mean, that has something
to do with the nature
of the physical world.
And I don't really think
that's what people had in mind.
It's that the kinds of
things that we normally
think of being able
to do with a procedure
mathematically is exactly
the kinds of things
that you can do with
a Turing machine.
So somebody's pointing out,
trying to be helpful here,
maybe these folks are
asking about equivalents
of various different
computation models being
proved in the book, not the
Church-Turing thesis itself.
Well, I mean, the things
that we proved in lecture
are also proved in the book.
About the equivalence
of single tape machines,
multi-tape machines,
non-deterministic machines,
those are all
proved in the book.
I mean, there's lots
of models out there.
So we could spend a lot of
time proving equivalences.
And there are books that do
spend a lot of time proving
equivalences.
But I think what we've
given is probably enough.
That's a good question.
If you give an
algorithm, you don't
need to give the actual machine
going forward unless you're
explicitly asked to.
But yes, you don't have to
give the states and transitions
anymore.
OK.
So it's a little after 4:00.
I think I'm going to move
on to my next meeting.
So thank you for being here,
and I will see you on Tuesday.